foreign
because you can sit there and tell
people what to tell grieving people all
day long and that doesn't matter either
because I guess the answer is it's going
to take a lot of time and it's a lot of
hard work and so if you choose to enter
into somebody's grief which is poison
you need to be ready to take on some of
that poison yourself carry with them
[Music]
what's going on what's going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney's show
show about your mental and emotional
health and your marriage and your kids
what's going on with your neighbors
what's going on in your schools whatever
you got going on in your life when it
comes to being well being whole
relationships your mental health
we're here for you we're here for you if
you want to be on the show the show's
about real people going through real
problems in real in real time so if you
want to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k a couple of housekeeping notes
number one
dude shout out to Andrew who had baby
William and uh Andrew normally runs the
video cameras and all the YouTubey stuff
we have his very distant
replacement in here today Nate Dogg
uh not really
I mean you all know that like right like
there's the starting
lineup and then there's the backups I
know your show more than he does here we
go yeah but he's just behind you and
absorbs and and judges you
that's true it may be true that's true
no actually it's awesome you did you
actually like train Andrew
yeah I did
very cool hey uh we're excited baby
William is here and safe and beautiful
and
important news number two Kelly you're
moving back into your house
yes six months later we are in the
process of moving back in
from the great Christmas flood there's a
Christmas miracle
I don't know if it was a miracle it was
something it was a a
coming down from the heavens that's for
sure and then you moved in and then what
happened
our air conditioning unit went out
so we're actually we're moved in the
house but we're living in a hotel
because it's hot but they're putting the
air conditioning unit in today so we'll
be in the house officially tomorrow
if you see anybody on our team
walking around just holding a lightning
rod it's because of that because at some
point I'm becoming Kelly's you did
something in a former life to anger the
God because it has been
a hell of a six months
it's been wild that's all I must say
good I'm glad that I have two panes of
glass separating the two of us and the
final thing is
my favorite supplements in the world
Thorn t-h-o-r-n-e go to thorn.com you
slash deloni for 25 off the best
supplements in the biz all right let's
go out to Dallas Texas and talk to Tori
what's up Tori
hey John it's so good to talk to you how
are you today I'm great how are you
I am wonderful all right so you sent me
OG a letter in the mail
I did because I really wanted to get
your input on some things and help kinda
ease my mind or something well I get a
lot I get a ton of letters and I
actually read them and they bring me joy
they're usually full of like hey this
great thing happened I just want to say
thank you and your emails on my desk it
was like whoa so yeah there's a lot
yeah all right so let's let's start at
square one and let's walk everybody
through it let's do it
oh gosh okay
um the long story short is my
mother-in-law ran off with her Twitter
Affair and she loved her kids her
grandkids her husband of 33 years
and it was just a shock to everybody
so is this way out of character for her
oh yeah oh yeah she was the um what you
would picture as the country bumpkin
mama
she took care of all the kids that ran
around the town and everybody would show
up you know and get their kool-aids and
she was just that place that you would
go and Trust
and you know talk to or like I said just
hang out on the porch and drink Gatorade
or something like that and then tell me
about this Twitter this Twitter Romance
all right yeah I think I don't I don't
even know how long it was going on
uh but she just up and left one day she
left a bracelet that all the kids had
caught in her I'm sorry I'm postpartum
I'm probably gonna cry hey cry all you
want to even if you're not postpartum
that's all good man this is this is this
is um
I mean on its face it's like there's no
way this happened and then like this
happened to a real family and this is
your favorite
and yeah it was
in a bracelet
entered but the kids got her
um on the table
and ran off with this guy
we we didn't see coming didn't have a
clue we thought she was out for a run
but she never came back
um so yeah all this happened like two
months before my husband and I got
married I've been a part of the family
for like 13 years now
um so so you know she was like my second
home
when you say
go ahead y'all were dating for 13 years
before you got married
no and we've been married for five years
now um she left right before we got
married okay so is she still gone after
five years with this Twitter Twitter
lover
yes so that like they made a go of it
this just wasn't like a bad decision and
six months later she came crawling back
or whatever
um yeah another part of the story she
came back three times
just in a matter of like six months and
I think one of it was like
you know try to put final things in
order for her divorce against my
husband's dad because he came home from
work and the house was absolutely trash
of like paperwork he beats to the house
and stuff like that
so is it divorce final
oh yeah okay
oh yeah oh she got remarried wow okay so
five years ago
you're
now mother-in-law shocks everybody
and meets some dude on Twitter and runs
off and yeah two months before our
wedding right did she did she come to
your wedding punched to my husband
did she come to your wedding
no Okay so
and but she didn't just leave she cut
ties she left things that your kids had
got I mean she she said I want to no
longer be a part of this family right
yeah so
he left we were all trying to look for
and figure out what the heck was going
on she sends a text message to the
oldest son
and the message said I didn't just leave
your dad I left all of you
okay so five years later
you write me
how can I help now
um
before before we come in I I want
everyone listening to this
um
it's so easy when you hear the sentence
he left her or she left him after 30
years she just she took off
I want everyone listening to hear five
years later the ripple effect that has
still continued to Rattle this family
the kids wondering what was it about us
that grandma left the husband that's
like whoa what's going on the
daughter-in-law who had a picture of her
life with this woman who suddenly right
so this thing rattles this isn't just a
matter of Oh Sheila
When anybody leaves a family it
Everything Burns to the ground right
oh yeah
okay so how can I help you today I'm
just I'm so sorry
well they're um you know in my letter I
explained that um there's a few more
details
um a few more details and a lot more
resentment toward her
um so my question is how do I accept her
coming into my home
you don't because I just are you told
her not be here at all she does not come
into your home
she doesn't come into your home
you don't waste an ounce of energy on
resentment
she she looked at your table and said I
am cashing out my my seat here I'm out
it was her words to her own son that
said I'm leaving y'all too
cool okay okay
mother and he still wants to have a
relationship with her
he
has to put you first
and there comes a moment when you have
to say
not it's not about her
she needs to be moved off to the side
here where she asked to be put
it's about you looking at your husband
saying I don't want people in my house
who destroyed my husband I don't want
people in my house who are of such poor
character
and who are so low
that they would do that to their own
kids I don't want that type of person
around my children
and here's the kicker I feel unsafe when
your mom is in our presence
and then your husband has a choice
he can choose his mom
who left him
over his wife and then y'all have bigger
fish to fry
or he can do the right thing
and honor his wife
you see how this has very little to do
with mom this has very much to do with a
marriage right now
okay
and this is a hard question I'm about to
ask you because this isn't what you
wrote about in your letter but how's
your marriage
oh wonderful say that again I I it was
just a little bit garbled
and if something comes up you know I
immediately go and talk to him about it
like hey let's look at this this way
um we've used better help and even the
therapist on there he said I don't know
why y'all are calling me y'all are great
that's so good so so is is your husband
trying to reconcile something or is he
trying to prop up a fantasy
yes
but you know he had this picture of his
mom and his dad in this beautiful 33
years of marriage
and it was gone an instant
in a weird way this may not be a perfect
one-to-one analogy
but
if his mom had died
he would have been able to grieve her
loss
but she asked
no she told the family y'all are dead to
me
exactly yeah I totally agree and so
there's a ghost hanging on out there
that he can't fully let go of
yeah and and him and his siblings and
her you know they've gotten to a point
where they
um have this group chat and they're
always updating each other
and I tell him you know you need to back
off that because she doesn't care if she
cared she'd be here
's the hard part
you can only control you
yeah
so
um
I would just be very clear about my
boundaries
and there's been a few moments in my
life when I'm gonna invite friends over
or and and they're I mean they're not
bad people they're just crass or
whatever they're but their people I've
known for years and my wife has said I
do not want them around our kids
and I honored my wife
because she was right
and there's been times I told her I
don't want so and so around our family I
don't like so and so in my house
and she has said cool
I'm all in on us
and so you can't be you can you can do
whatever you want I would not spend my
energy trying to tell him what he should
or shouldn't be doing
I would be very clear about your safety
and your expectations for interactions
and dude I I'm I am I would love to talk
to your husband I'd love for him to call
in too
and I promise if he'll if he'll call in
or write it I know yeah he would be
willing to do that I mean like I said
we're we're great communicators if he
wants to come in um uh stay on the line
and uh Jenna will give you direct access
that way we'll make sure we get it
um I'd love to have him on
but at the end of the day as hard as
this is he's got to choose his wife over
his mom
and quite honestly all of us have to do
that my mom's amazing
and my wife comes first
it's my wife
um it doesn't mean that I advocate my
responsibility to my mom that I somehow
less than oh but I I made a choice I
made a lifelong commitment to my wife
you throw on top of that a mom who is
just flat out evil and you ain't gonna
be around my kids
and I'd prefer our family to grieve this
loss finally with a period at the end of
it and walk away now
mom shows up at your front door
on her knees begging I screwed up I blew
up everything I ruined everybody's life
and I'm so sorry
and you want to start a multi-year
healing process maybe
but anything short of that Mom she told
me she was explicit she told you I'm
leaving y'all too
cool
I hate that for you
moms aren't supposed to leave
so so so so so sorry stay on the line
we'll be uh we'll be in touch
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey good folks Dr John deloney here look
you made it halfway through the year
congratulations and maybe you started
this year being a little bit more
intentional about mindfulness and then
the culture convinced you that you gotta
run harder snap into a Slim Jim and you
find yourself back on social media
watching nonsense influencers sharing
their life hacks for doing more and more
and more listen my friends
don't sacrifice sleep at the altar of
productivity hustling is well and good
working hard accomplishing things is
great but burnout is very real and
burnout is when your body just says I'm
out
and as a society we are exhausted and
when you're running on empty you gotta
remember to recharge your body sleep is
the number one way to recharge your
physical and mental health and for me
getting great sleep starts with a great
mattress and that's why I love dream
cloud and right now dream Cloud
mattresses are running an awesome offer
exclusively for our listeners 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings it's time to start
prioritizing your sleep go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney that's dreamcloudsleep.com
with code John deloney
all right we are back hey this is
um a big deal for me
so I recently had a great great friend
of mine
a award-winning multi-award-winning
um young adult author
and long long time great friend
he is a Rancher and a
an author and he is also a creative
writing teacher
um really an extraordinary guy
and we have many many similar viewpoints
on the world
and we also disagree big time on a few
big big issues
and I love him and he has written some
of the most extraordinary books I'm I'm
a sucker for the old Where the Red Fern
Grows and Goonies and stand by me those
old stories where people are outside and
they're having adventures and um he his
name is Nate Dahlstrom so in the
interview you may you may hear me refer
to him as Nate he writes under the name
s j Dahlstrom and he's got a wild or
good Wilder good is the main character
um and it's a multi-book adventure
series and so if you don't have a
picture of what life without screens
looks like anymore these books are the
antidote
um black Brock Brothers is just one of
them
um they're so extraordinary and I'm
gonna Link in the show notes
um to wildergood.com amazon.com where
you can pick up these books but I had
Nate on for
we did a long interview and we ended up
breaking it up into seven segments that
we're gonna release over the course of
the next few shows
but Nate and I have been
um through the ringer together in a few
a few big issues and we share similar
passions about things and we disagree on
some things like I said
but
in this upcoming segment
um
we're gonna really go down a rabbit hole
with some personal things that I don't
think I've talked about very much on
this show if at all about grief
and he has been one of my chief
Educators in my life on wrestling with
grief and dealing with grief and how you
show up
the right way
so this isn't an interview please don't
just skip over this one this is an
important one and this is a guy with a
lot of wisdom and a guy that iron
sharpens iron that um
I love sitting with and sharing time
with and sharing space with because it
makes me a better dad and it makes me a
better husband and it makes me a better
thinker and it makes me a better writer
and we all need people like that in our
life
but also Nate showed up for me in a
couple of places that um
will end up having a
changing my family tree sort of impact
so check out this conversation on Grief
this isn't an academic conversation this
is a honest honest conversation
about grief with me and my friend Nate
SJ Dahlstrom
trying to think there's those moments
you have in your life that there's
there's 10 or 15 across my life that I
can point back to and say I was
different after this I was different
after this
so
to put in context here's the story story
is
um
all through college I had this Basset
Hound that I loved just was my hound dog
slept in my van slept in my pillow slept
in your bed yeah it was not great I was
not a hygienic before you were married
yes and um
then when we got married she got moved
to the couch and
when I took that dog she got sick when I
took that dog and put her down I I don't
remember my lifetime weeping that hard
like it was from my guts that was my
hound dog and I don't remember I mean I
remember you loving that dog but it was
Heavy yeah it is a terrible moment when
your buddy dies but then I immediately
Sheila and I went to the store and had a
rebound dog which is always a terrible
idea so we got another Basset Hound
within a week or two and her name was
Maria
she was terrible she was about as
worthless she was a walking football
just was not a good dog and then Hank
came along
so Hank comes along and that was his dog
and they sat around and he babbled and
she just laid there like a sealed giant
giant basset hounds do
so I took a job in another town and
Sheila was finishing up her dissertation
my wife was finished up her research and
so
um we were traveling back and forth and
one day our families were going to spend
the day out of your Ranch and Marie had
gotten real sick and then she bit Hank
and it hurt him and then I took her to
the vet and the vet was like man she's
got she's real sick so I called Sheila
and said hey today's got to be the day
that I put this dog down and
I said y'all head out to the ranch and
I'll meet you out there
so I'm sitting there with this dog and
with that I don't like but this is
always just a hard moment it is Hank's
dog and
um how old is the dog at that point 10
or 11. yeah something like that and Hank
was
um I think Hank was four I think Hank
was four
and you put a dog down and then you just
walk away and they put it in the some
City in Center City incinerator and uh
sitting there and I for some reason I
had this strange moment and I picked up
my cell phone and called you and said
hey this is weird it's seven in the
morning or eight in the morning I'm
sitting in a vet's office
would it be all right if I
I feel weird about leaving my dog here
and it feels like a right thing to do to
take the dog and bury it I don't have
anywhere to bury it can I bring it out
to the ranch and you got real quiet and
it was a long beat it was one of those
that feels like 10 seconds so it's
probably two seconds
and you said if you don't take this
moment to teach your kid about death
you're not the father I thought you were
something like that something very
Nathan and it was something impactful so
judgmental but it was
yeah and so we get out to the ranch and
um you had set up a little shovel and a
big shovel and Hank and I went out and
dug a hole for that dog and we prayed
over that dog and we talked about that
dog and
I remember putting the dog in and Hank
saying hey don't bury the head and I
said no Hank the dogs the dogs die like
it was a it was a hard moment but then
two years five years ten years as I lost
grandparents and friends of mine
for a little little kid we called back
to that over and over and there was just
this moment of the importance of
teaching my son about grief and then
several years later maybe uh yeah
several years later
I get a call from My Wife and she is
she's crying so hard I can't hear on the
phone and I keep saying I'm at the law
school there working and I I can't
understand you can't understand you and
she had had an ectopic pregnancy that
had ruptured and
she had sat at home and we'd had several
pregnancy losses and she just said this
isn't happening it's not happening and
she tried to tough it out she's a tough
West Texas girl and then she'd almost
bled out in her living room and she had
driven herself to the hospital and then
called me on the way again I didn't know
what was going on I didn't even know
what ectopic pregnancy was I drive up
there and I had Hank I picked him up
from school and I saw my wife in a
wheelchair with the head of the OB GYN
and I remember looking at the doctor
thinking
oh this this is it like this this bad
somewhere along the way maybe I called
your wife or so I somebody came and got
Hank and I still don't know who came and
got Hank but I'm sitting by myself in
this waiting room and they were had
taken Sheila in and we're doing
emergency surgery on her and
um I just sitting there by myself I'm
just sitting there and then you walked
in and just sat right by me and you said
nothing we didn't talk and then when the
nurse came in and said we weren't able
to save the pregnancy but your wife's
gonna be okay I'll I remember I'll never
forget you reached over and grabbed my
shoe and you had you had tears that I
wasn't able to cry yet and that was an
important like just sitting with
somebody no words no nothing stitched on
a pillow just this heavy moment
but it was also an invitation to this is
what Sharon grief looks like with people
that you love you sit with them and when
I look back at our culture I think one
of the things we've done is we've
outsourced all these things to other
people and we've pathologized discomfort
we made just being uncomfortable a bad
thing that we have to solve and fix
and when it comes to grief maybe the
number one question I get on this show
privately personally through social
media on emailed in his questions on how
do I grieve what's the point why don't
we do this when we do this
talk to us man because you've been a key
you've been a key teacher for me in a
couple of big areas on that
the the idea that you got to head into
the storm versus walking away from it
well those are
holy things and as your story manifests
uh What mattered was not anything
anybody said you know and so
uh
how do you show up to help and don't say
anything I don't know
obviously The Book of Job teaches us
that really carefully that we use said
Shiva with someone you sit seven days
and you just grieve and put ashes on
your head and tear your clothing and
don't give them a bunch of
uh mumbo-jumbo psychology or from the
sermon that said what do you tell
grieving people uh because you can sit
there and tell people what to tell
grieving people all day long and that
doesn't matter either uh because I guess
the answer is it's going to take a lot
of time and it's a lot of hard work uh
Jesus said I'm a Man of Sorrows and
acquainted with grief and you didn't get
that from reading a book yeah you know
you got that from uh being acquainted
with grief and nobody wants that yeah uh
it's a curse
it's knowledge you don't want to have
and so uh
to answer your question is uh
Solomon says if you want wisdom go to
the house of mourning and uh well
nobody's going to go to the house in the
morning
uh they don't want that type of
knowledge but I mean uh
sit with people and be quiet but but to
enter into that that kind of grief uh I
mean it's going to take something of you
uh you ever hear the
word poultice a poultice is something
somebody has a wound
maybe like a snake bite or something
there's some kind of poison you put this
poultice it can be like a piece of meat
it can be a a bunch of vegetation and
you put that poultice on the wound
and what happens is as the poultice
dries it sucks out the poison it's been
around for a long long time and so if
you choose to enter into somebody's
grief which is poison
you need to be ready to take on some of
that poison yourself carry it with them
and that's that's a really really dumb
thing to do
it's the right thing to do uh but you
know it's not
if you really jump into somebody's grief
you're going to get poisoned from them
and that's just you you can't in a
lifetime how many how many how many
people can you do that with very few
yeah uh until you look at our police
officers are burned the social workers
of birds the hospital attendees are
burnt it's just exhausting and and and
do it really honestly because that's you
know that kind of grief is a is a
Madness I've compared it to you know
like you know people probably don't get
this but to being in love and when you
fall in love you're you're everything is
kind of fake you're floating along On A
Cloud you're in a you're in a sub world
and that's what that kind of grief is
you're in a sub world nothing it looks
to you like it looks to everybody else
and uh
um but you know the gift of animals
if you're parenting properly in my
opinion
the animals teach you that first you
know your first dog you bury and if you
haven't sanitized that experience for
your kid and said oh the doggie went to
heaven and just go burn it and throw
away the ashes if you let somebody walk
through that well they've got a little
bit of a taste of what it's going to be
like when you bury a Granddad
or a family member
and so that's a great gift that God gave
us that relationship you know with the
dog particularly uh which is really
unique like why don't we ball our eyes
out when dogs die uh you know it's that
little edinic relationship that slipped
through uh but uh but it matters and it
teaches you a little bit uh what that's
going to feel like because of course
life is a complete tragedy yeah just
over and over again we're just we're
just waiting for that the way I've
described grief or tried to wrap my head
around a definition it's it's the gap
between what you hoped for and what you
wanted and what actually happened and
there's that space and we run from it
and
it's been my experience that the longer
you run from it it the clot it doesn't
ever stop or there's that there's that
great quote uh pain deferred as pain
Amplified at some point you got to turn
and go in it and
um walk through it what's your wisdom
for somebody that's been avoiding it for
a long time
the wisdom for someone who's been
avoiding it for it for some time uh I
guess you're a West Texas Rancher just
got work to do let's go do it let's go
get it done right
yeah I mean all I can say is what
happened to me and the only thing you
know why or why did we survive what
happened to us uh I I don't know nature
killed me it wasn't
people and you say oh nature healed you
and that means nothing uh
I I'll just say this I remember one time
uh
I saw a deer in the morning in that time
come out and start eating oak leaves and
something kind of cracked and I think
what I figured that was was Beauty
is you have
incredible misery to go through in this
life and that's promised for sure
Genesis 3 there's a curse upon this
Earth you're waiting for cancer car
wreck but here's the one lucky thing
that happened that beauty got into
so while that curse got in a little bit
of the Beauty from the identic
experiences here and so that beauty
began to
patch me one to the next to the next to
the next and so a model I developed in
those times was was was to find beauty
because you can for sure find ugly you
can for sure find the curse in the world
but if you find that beauty that beauty
you know of
I still have a friendship and it's
honest you know uh a sunset you know
wildflowers you know those things
literally began to save me if you if you
can make your whole life watching birds
come meet your bird feeder you know and
like when you're about when you're
drowning you know the beauty of birds
and and singing and the seasons all
those things it sounds trite but when
you're gasping for air five seconds of
air really matters yeah you're not
worried about the year of air you're
looking for the next five seconds of air
and and God allowed Beauty into the
world and it's all around us and uh if
you will sit there and wait on it that
beauty will get you through five seconds
and then ten seconds and then 15 seconds
and eventually you kind of make it
through the day uh
fine Beauty yeah that's that's the
answer
one of my favorite things is is
walking out of
especially back when we lived in the
same Community I'd walk out of grad
school
with all the PHD people sitting around
the table and then we'd head out to the
ranch
and one of the psychological constructs
they would pass along for instance would
be
what the brain focuses on is what the
brain sees everywhere and
as Neuroscience to that and then to go
sit with my buddy who's a rancher in
West Texas to say I'm gonna find beauty
there's a the answers in nature right we
can find in our textbooks but you can
live it here
yeah this is there no the those
fingerprints aren't everything he did
you know uh you you look really really
close out of Van Gogh you see the van
Gogh brush Strokes that are only Van
Gogh's uh and nobody else can do those
well you look really really close at the
footprints and the fingerprints all over
our natural world God is he's going to
speak to you and you have to be quiet
and listen and uh
it gives you just enough at the right
time
um but you know there's no there's just
there's no there's no quick fixes for
for any of that
um you got to be willing to take
somebody's poison and you've just gotta
wait on it and eventually maybe you'll
survive
surround yourself with beauty
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Spencer
in Fresno California what's up Spencer
hey John how are you doing we're rocking
dude what are you up to
oh just uh just surviving the Heat
is it hot there in Fresno
oh it's uh we're we're not close to the
ocean so it uh it heats up a lot all
right well it's beautiful here in
Nashville so haha I'm just kidding we'll
make it over one day there you go come
on over man everyone else in your
neighborhood's moved in so y'all should
join y'all should join her so what's up
dude
um my question for you
is I've had a gambling addiction
specifically to sports betting that's
rained havoc in my life for years
as I work on overcoming it I'm
struggling to find peace in my life and
also to find life fun and enjoyable to
live
how am I able to do that oh man
all right so you read that question
there right
I did all right so
just speak from your heart
what's been going on in the last few
years how long has this been going on
um close to about eight years okay
what's your total loss
um if I'm being honest I don't know
exactly because even as I've tried to go
back and look at it is from so many
different places yes uh but but but
total my guess is somewhere between four
and five hundred thousand okay
when you say wreaked havoc
besides the financial losses or what is
what is it what does it cost you
um I think I figured the financial
losses have obviously uh played effects
in other places in my life
um I think I have seen it more rain
havoc in my ability to wake up and enjoy
life every day and um I mean that in the
way of just
um interactions with my wife
interactions with my friends
um my ability to want to go do fun
things
I um I feel almost a little bit numb
to it and uh I think the scariest part
to me is as I've come back is
is learning to I think I live so much in
the past from my from my younger self my
high school self
that I uh that I I just wish that I
could go back to a time when I remember
times that were so fun living in the
moment yeah
how old are you man
I'm 25.
so some broad
you mind if I teach for just like 30
seconds then we'll get back to your
situation because I want to paint a big
picture here okay absolutely
um
the last data point I read was
200 billion dollars in Wagers over the
last five to six years
to put that into context
if we spent 40 billion dollars until
that would end Global hunger
no more hungry people for 40 billion a
year for seven years
we've spent 200 billion dollars gambling
on sports or he's an even better one it
would cost about 20 billion dollars to
end homelessness in the United States
once and for all
210x
we've blown gambling and here's where it
really I just makes me sick to my
stomach man because I I dude I I'm
heartbroken for you
because you're an addict right yeah I am
and
but this is a different kind of
addiction because you know if you're a
Coke addict you go to jail right
uh you know if you're a Coke addict at
some point it kills you
yeah but we have the government and
educational agencies promoting this
as a good thing a way to help out your
community and have a little fun too
because
proceeds go to uh
government coffers and it goes to help
education
so it's kind of like taking cocaine in
fentanyl sales
for and donating that to the local
schools so they can get more Chromebooks
or whatever crap
yeah total it's just total BS dude and
it just it makes me sick
um
take me back to how this started man
yeah um I think in the beginning it
started uh I mean it started in all fun
I was in a I was in a really low point
in my life
what happened yeah
um I grew up in a really religious
family okay and a great relationship
with my family and great relationship
with my parents but
um I ended up going on a mission with my
church
and uh anyway I came back earlier than I
thought I would did you get in trouble
earlier
no not in trouble just due to mental
health just with um uh issues with
depression okay anxiety whereas with my
body wasn't functioning uh like it
should be anyway I uh I went home and I
just felt a lot of Shame and a lot of
guilt in my life for not being able to
complete that okay
and uh was that guilt in shame
reinforced by your parents and Friends
um
by my friends I I think over time my
parents have learned a little bit more
of how to deal with it but when I came
home I was supposed to be out there for
close to two years and I came back after
six months okay
and uh so no one was really expecting it
and uh my siblings you know they all
welcome and I think my parents they were
just a little bit more like what are you
doing that type thing
um
and so I think that was hard and so
instead of ever like facing anything
instead of going out I I just didn't
want to leave the house and I ended up
going over to my sisters who lived in
South Carolina
and uh I stayed with her and while I was
over there she was she was just telling
me you know every Sunday
they just bet on a football game while
it plays and I was like that's awesome
and uh you know they were they were just
betting a couple of bucks and anyway
ever since that day I uh it became my
comfort
and it became the thing I went to every
time because I I think I felt very
abandoned in that time in my life
um so over time it became my crutch and
um can I be honest can I be honest with
you please I I think you were probably
felt abandoned before that
I tend to
I like to start at a place when I hear
somebody say I'm really struggling with
depression anxiety I needed to come home
I like to start from a place that your
body was doing exactly what it needed to
do to keep you safe
not that it was malfunctioning
or wasn't working as it should
and that would lead me to believe that
there was some sort of Preparatory
challenges I mean there was some sort of
environment that wasn't set up before
you left
there wasn't deep anchors and Deep Roots
so that you can go do something really
hard like a two-year Mission at 18 years
old that's tough man that's scary that's
isolating it's all that stuff and you've
got to be anchored into something way
bigger than you
am I right
um yeah I mean it's hard because
I feel like I had good support from my
family okay
um and I had a really good friend group
I think I think as growing up I was
always like a really small kid it wasn't
until I turned about 20 that I actually
grew and
but I mean all through I I always felt
like I was like the little sibling even
in high school and even coming out I was
always the guy that that worked six
years younger than he was and so I I
don't think I ever really felt like I
was a real friend I always felt like I
was the Friend's Brother okay
so you've always been on the outside
looking in we always felt like on the
outside looking in and even if people
invited you because they liked you you
had another story as to why they weren't
really inviting you because they liked
you
and you got a brain screaming at you
dude we got to plug in we got to plug in
we got to plug in and then you go off to
another country you go off to another
state where you know nobody and they say
go get them
yeah man I mean that's that's I mean
it's a recipe for anxiety it's a recipe
for a body shutting the system down
and then you come back and then were you
18 when you came back
yeah it was yeah and then your sister
handed you a a double uh double Jack and
Coke and was like hey we just do this on
Sundays and your body went ah right
yeah yeah man
what do you do for a living
um I work in uh cells so if you do you
make a whole bunch of money or have you
have you mortgaged and leveraged your
soul
um no I I actually make a really good
income okay and I think that's the part
that is hard is I think sometimes I bang
my head against the wall where I'm like
it doesn't really matter what I make
because it's just all going down the
drain anyway I know but there's there's
listeners that if they gambled 500 000
over seven years that would mean they've
taken out two mortgages and they've
stolen money but if you make 250 000 a
year over seven years you could blow
that kind of money
right no it's it's something I'm able to
on the financial part
um I'll I'll be out of debt here in the
next about uh two months okay
um tell me about your marriage bro
um it's great my wife's fantastic
um I'm I've been only married for nine
months
does she know the extent of this
um she has and I've more not when we
first got married
um I had brought it up to her but
um I think I think it was hard that I
wanted her to pry more than she would
and so it just kind of got left on the
doorstep and I said hey I have kind of a
problem with this and you know she said
thanks for letting me know but she never
asked any additional questions
um since then I've realized that if I
ever want to make a change in my life I
can't wait for somebody else to come to
me
um well hold on bro that's I mean you
kind of presented like the Bro Flex out
version
you're right you've got to be honest
about it right but yeah
you can't White Knuckle your way through
this
yeah
and you can't you can't over discipline
your way through this and I'm a guy that
really preaches discipline because I
think in a lot of areas
man if people just sleep and they would
have great friends and be disciplined
about exercise a lot of their life's
problems would would shift this is not
one of those moments
yeah
I think
I think recently I've realized that a
little bit in the past uh
well a little while and I and I realized
that I'm just so poor with with money
and where it's going and so uh I my
wife's just I mean
she doesn't have the same addictions
that I do Spencer the way you just said
that is like saying yeah I just realized
that I have a problem with
um
cocaine and how much of it just gets in
my nose
yeah
you were over your head man
and until you're ready to fully submit
this thing's gonna keep growing like a
dragon
yeah
I um
the first steps I've done is uh I gave
my wife all of
um my debit and my credit cards and I
gave her everything
and I said hey set me up on a couple
hundred week budget Mac just for you
know food and gas
and then uh and then that way right now
we can both see the accounts that I only
have access to a couple hundred bucks
and uh that will work for about eight
weeks for you
nope it won't it will work for about
four weeks for you
yeah and I think that's the part that
I'm nervous about I'm telling you right
now Spencer you you are bro dude you are
doing everything you can to avoid the
reality of this
and that's that's totally fine that's
totally fine
how do I uh how do I not avoid it you
sit down and tell your wife honey I am
in full-blown addict
I haven't been fully honest with you I
cannot control this
I've been gambling for seven years since
I was a kid
I'm struggling with depression I'm
struggling with anxiety and this is
every bit a um getting drunk every day
of my life
or every bit doing heroin every day of
my life
and I've got to start going to GA gamble
is anonymous I gotta get a group I don't
have to get a sponsor because I'm over
my head and I'm sorry I didn't tell you
the truth
that's where you got started
yeah anything short of that my friend
you're too smart you make too much money
you're trying to do gentle workarounds
with a beautiful wife who doesn't know
how bad this is
yeah
Fair
that's there I think that uh I think
that's after a while too you lie to
yourself for so long of course you do
yeah man
and uh I guess like I don't know too
because I I've sat down with my wife and
when I when I basically said hey you
need to take all the cards away I told
her that
uh you know I was like I like I'm an
addict and I can't control this
um
but I know as addicts do that even in
ways that I don't know if you really
want to do it
you'll find a way to find a way you've
set yourself up to commit a crime
or you've set yourself up to really
violate a core tenet of your marriage
which is we will tell the truth to one
another
yeah because you put boundaries in place
without dealing with the core issue
yeah
in a core issue I I always look at
addiction any sort of addiction as
whether it's work or whether it's drugs
or whether it's gambling or sex whatever
it happens to be it that's relational in
origin
until you deal with that black hole man
this little kid that doesn't feel like
he's enough and feels like he's on the
outside and feels like he's a burden and
feels like
um he just has to
accomplish and Achieve so we can get
love around him and he failed this big
accomplishment and achievement that
everyone talked about since the day he
was born until he was 18.
until you deal with that
and the grief around that and the wait a
minute I don't suck I'm not a piece of
crap
I'm a good man I work hard I love my
family
until you deal with those things brother
Nothing's Gonna taste right
yeah of course you're not you're you're
not gonna
be able to see a vision of your life
with happiness and laughter and joy
yeah I promise you it's there
but you can't end around it you got to
go through it
how do I
to go back and say Hey I want to deal
with these issues and these core issues
from growing up
where would where would someone like me
start Gamblers Anonymous
you have to you have to be honest out
loud with a group of people who will
look Square through you
who won't put up with any of you if
you've been gambling like this for this
long and you're a world-class salesman
you can tell anybody anything right
yeah yes
you are a Wordsmith if there ever was
one you're Shakespeare and so you've got
to sit in a room with people who
they will sit back and look at you and
you will know that they know
and then you got to be honest
and then you're gonna hear a bunch of
other stories and you're gonna go whoa
that's me too
and then you're gonna have people that
you call
at four in the morning when you can't
sleep and you're out of town on a sales
thing and you are logging into your
computer or picking up your phone and
you re you re-uh download those apps
and you got somebody looks in your eye
and says I will be here for you 24 7
365. I love you that much you call me
and then you're going to get to the core
issue of what happens just before you
get that impulse to gamble
yeah yeah and that's what you got to
lock in on that just takes time there is
no way to think your way through it
because look dude you know this is
ruining things
you know
I do know there's not a way to think it
out
you gotta just walk through and face the
dragon and you cannot do that alone
and you especially can't do it with some
wife who's nine months in who's trying
to love you the best she can but she
does not know what she's in for
yeah Fair
that's fair I haven't met somebody who's
a full like full-blown over their head
into something
who is fully laid out everything in
front of his wife
I don't I don't know that guy until
they're ready to get stone sober when's
the last time you gambled
um about two weeks ago
when's the last time you really gambled
two weeks ago like for real though
that's the last time I did it what was
it on
it was on a uh a soccer match how much
uh it spread out between a few different
sites but it probably would have been
about fifteen hundred dollars total okay
are you starting to itch now
um
it's hard I don't the
I've gone in Cycles my whole life when I
go too much into debt
then the edge wears down but as soon as
there's money The Edge just skyrockets
and uh I'm at a point where I'm in debt
and I don't have uh I don't have money
and that's when I basically given
everything over but I I think that's
again what scares me is when money
starts flowing
there you go now now's the moment
yeah I had a I had a professor one time
she told me the hardest part about the
worst part about counseling is people
people wait until things are on fire
before they go she said it's like
waiting till you get the flu to go to
the gym for the first day to start your
workout program that's the worst that
you're sick the best day to go to the
gym is when you feel great the best time
to start going to counseling is when
things are awesome and you can actually
hear and start practicing things and
you're not running for your life you
have a moment where you don't have any
money you're broke you're in debt you're
in a hole and you're embarrassed and
you're ashamed of it and you're not
going to gamble in these moments because
your body's
telling you I mean you're lucky on that
one because I've talked to Gamblers who
they'll they'll borrow and just borrow
until they got a steal and whatever
you're not there for whatever reason now
is a perfect moment
so before the day's over brother
before the day is over
you pull out your phone and you find the
local Gamblers Anonymous in your area
or a local CA group or if you have to
and all they have is a local AAA group
go there
you have to take a knee in front of a
group of men and women who have been
there and can see you and say we know
and we'll walk with you
and then at some point you're gonna have
to get with a licensed counselor who
knows what they're doing and start to
walk back this idea that you somehow
don't belong to anybody anywhere at any
time because it's not true you do
you're one of my friends now
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy about your past change your future
we're gonna hook you up with that and
then brother I will walk with you every
step of the way
and here's what that means that means
you go to meetings and you call me in 30
days I want to hear an update and I'll
be willing to update everybody out there
if you go to meetings every day for the
next 30 days I would love that
I'll also be here if you choose to get
off the line and you are about to make
the call tonight you don't make it
in six months when your wife finally
finds out how bad this is I'll be here
then too
I'm in the Long Haul with you I'll I'll
take your call every time you call man
she got some hard choices to make ahead
of you and I hope you'll look in the
mirror and say dude Spencer's worth
being well Spencer's worth being whole
see you soon my brother we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back and Kelly has a
special segment
reminds me of
is whenever we used to watch you know
sitcoms and there was always a very
special episode and it always dealt with
like drugs tried weed exactly you know
when Jesse Spano took the speed pills
you know
something like that so it's quite that
life all right shattering it kind of is
here we go uh so we got an email
um from a listener and the way you are
smiling I know this is not going to be
in my favor go ahead no it
it's not in mine
[Laughter]
it's probably my mom no okay go ahead
this is uh January and she emailed in
and I'm just going to read some videos
you were calling out no it was great
it's a great letter okay it's fantastic
says your show has always helped me
reflect on different areas of my life
but I found one of your most recent
videos to be particularly profound why
America is obsessed with True Crime
I started this video with a false sense
of moral superiority for I seldom
consume media related to True Crime I do
however enjoy scary movies for the
longest time I Justified this that I
Justified this interest by telling
myself it's just fiction and no one is
actually getting hurt
that was until you shared something that
your dad told you I just can't ever
imagine thinking that this is
entertainment
that sentence struck me like a lightning
bolt I found myself re-examining my
interest I've had since childhood and it
made me feel uneasy
I think this is because of the extent to
which I have woven scary stories into my
identity
then she goes on to talk about how she
has been writing a book kind of a horror
book and she was having trouble with the
um violent scenes and she thought it was
just writer's block
then she said she decided to watch a few
scenes from a recent scary movie in
hopes of feeling inspired instead I was
left feeling disgusted and I spent the
rest of the weekend trying to figure out
why
I concluded that horror stories are
rooted in trauma the trauma fictional
characters experience is not as divorced
from reality as I once believed while
Freddy Krueger may not exist outside the
Silver Screen there are plenty of
monsters in the real world who can take
away everything we have
the concept of someone losing it all is
hard to justify as entertaining
regardless of whether it's fiction
so while I can't say I'll never watch
another scary movie I will be more
mindful of my reaction to that type of
content I also plan to continue to write
my story but I will no longer do it
writing such violent chapters
I struggle to imagine violence is
entertainment
wow
wow and as the uh
well how does that make you feel well
whenever we got it honestly I told Jenna
and you can tell your dad this that
sentence has stuck with me and I even
told my husband that about I can't
imagine that this is a form of
entertainment and it just it did it has
lived rent-free in my brain ever since
that day of like
ew I don't like how that feels
yeah I mean it haunted me back when he
told me when I was 12 or how old I was
yeah just that idea of
and then there's been a couple there's a
couple of really popular murder podcasts
that I don't listen to because I don't I
think they're disrespectful have they
talk about the the acts and I don't
think it's respectful to the families
and so that that's something that's I've
been a little more aware of but still
the challenge is I think because I you
know I love scary movies I grew up on
them I like that
um
is where do I go
for that shot of adrenaline or that shot
of yeah
and
I'll just I mean if we're being honesty
I'll be honest
um
recently a conversation with my
counselor
it helped me to realize and it's
something I say on the show all the time
it's just hard to see it when you're
looking in the mirror
I'm having to practice not being so spun
up all the time because I've been spun
up for 35 years and what I thought was
felt normal I've come to find out
shocking it's a lot for everybody around
me and so when I'm feeling at peace my
body feels sleepy my body feels depressy
and it's not it's just finally operating
at a low so I'm not feeling that same
need to go get jolted out of everything
because I'm finally in a different
physiological State you know what I mean
oh I do because I've been um as
everybody knows we deal with um a
mentally ill daughter at home and so
I've been working with my doctor to work
on my cortisol because I'm high cortisol
24 7 because of our situation and
because of this show and well it doesn't
help
and so I'm more aware of that now and
we're working on like actually I just
went yesterday and had some tests done
for the cortisol so they could figure
out what we could do to bring it down
and so I like those kind of movies my
son and I like we watch them together
the black phone is one of our new
favorite movies that's ever been out but
I like that and even as I've been more
aware of
wow this isn't healthy for my body to
live this High cortisol all the time
I've been more cognizant of well maybe I
won't need that like something
that there's a reason that I could
looking for that because it keeps me up
here because otherwise I don't know what
to do yes with it and the other like
what do I do it's
oh just go to sleep yeah just be I don't
have to sit down and read a book right
right it might be about murder too so
again I have a lot of things to work on
I saw somebody recently on Instagram
said uh I would do anything for eight
hours of sleep and somebody's like would
you just go to bed early and or exercise
and go to bed on time and they're like
not that not that right so good for you
Kelly way to go January
shout out man mad respect that's big
time
and to my old man
look at you drop in Pearls of Wisdom
when I was a little kid that that hung
in there
he probably has his top ten list and
I don't remember any of those I just
remember that line that was a good one
well it's true that sometimes the things
you say that you don't think your kids
catch oh I catch it all they catch it
and then one of these days that comes
back and you know it's that whole ripple
effect because look what he's doing now
man look at that all right hey everybody
stay in school don't do drugs Joe let's
kick the music up
the little jangly jangly jingly
hey I love you guys
appreciate y'all being with us we'll see
you soon
[Music]